signing up for all of that exposure
again was really yeah the hills new
beginning stars Brody Jenner and Caitlyn
Carter recently announced they're
splitting after five years together but
one thing's for sure there's still a lot
of love between the former couple let's
been good overall you may have seen
these pics floating around over the
weekend
that's Caitlyn on vacation with Miley
Cyrus who also recently split from her
hubby Liam Hemsworth well a source is
now exclusively opening up to ET
explaining that Brody is not only still
friends with Caitlyn but also Miley and
Liam adding that Brody spoke to all of
them separately over the weekend quote
he still cares deeply for her and his
friendships with them he wants everyone
to be happy and live their best lives
Brody playfully acknowledged the pics on
social media over on his Instagram he
joked that pics of him and Liam holding
hands on the beach who were coming soon
Miley even wrote back go take a nap in
your truck and cool off what's it like
sleeping in a car I came home to a
psychopath yelling and screaming at me
because I came home at a certain time
meanwhile Brody and Kaitlyn's
relationship is still playing out on the
hills in the most recent episode Caitlin
throws a black-tie gala and Brody shows
his support
don't stress you guys have done enough
this is incredible and everybody's go
stress ET sat down with the couple in
May ahead of the hills premiere they
opened up about exposing their personal
lives to the public and showing their
relationship on camera
reality TV in the past is up in great
for relationships in general it can be
very trying to like it not helped us but
it brought us closer together because it
was kind of like us against the world in
moments when filming the show sure so
other people chimed in he's already
planning on it not working